Générique
...
-Bonjour et bienvenue
pour un nouveau numéro
de "Politiques, à table" sur LCP.
On se retrouve,
comme chaque semaine,
autour d'un plat,
d'un dessert et d'un invité.
Prisca Thevenot, bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Merci d'être venue.
Avec moi,
pour présenter cette émission,
Jean-Pierre Montanay, bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Secrétaire d'Etat
chargée de la Jeunesse
et du Service national,
d'abord porte-parole du parti,
vous devenez députée, en 2022,
vous vous engagez en politique
pour Emmanuel Macron,
et son projet d'émancipation,
qui résonne en vous.
Vous avez fait vos études en ZEP,
à Stains, en Seine-Saint-Denis,
avant d'intégrer le prestigieux
lycée jésuite Franklin, dans le 16e
arrondissement,
puis une école de commerce,
et vous vous lancez
dans l'entreprenariat.
Vous êtes au gouvernement.
Tout ça aurait pu
vous monter à la tête,
mais non, vous avez choisi
de nous parler de vos origines.
Ca commence à l'île Maurice.
-Oui, en effet,
avec une spécialité mauricienne,
une recette insolite,
un plat insolite,
un bol renversé,
c'est assez drôle.
Et en dessert,
un crumble aux pommes.
Dans Le dessous des plats :
l'inflation alimentaire
plonge les jeunes
dans la précarité.
Nous avons suivi Mélissa
dans une collecte alimentaire.
-Dans Les pieds dans le plat,
l'obésité explose dans le monde,
la France n'est pas épargnée.
Les jeunes sont les plus touchés
à cause de la malbouffe.
-Allez, on passe à table.
Tout de suite :
Cuisine et confidences.
Jingle
-Alors, Prisca Thevenot,
avant même de connaître
votre recette,
j'avais dit à Brigitte :
"Avec un peu de 'bol',
"on aura un plat mauricien."
Je ne croyais pas si bien dire,
car on a, disons,
une double dose de bol.
On a le bol de goûter à la cuisine
de vos racines,
et le plat lui-même,
puisqu'il s'appelle,
je n'invente rien...
-Et la chance
de vous avoir avec nous.
-...le bol renversé.
Je ne savais pas que ça existait.
C'est un plat populaire
de l'île Maurice,
mais ses origines
sont plutôt chinoises.
Cette recette,
c'est un oeuf cuit au plat,
une couche de légumes, de viande,
de crevettes sautées au wok
et une couche de riz blanc.
On met le tout dans un bol :
l'oeuf, la viande puis le riz.
C'est un peu la tarte Tatin
du riz, et là, maintenant,
on a renversé le bol.
Il faut lever délicatement,
devant le convive.
-Allez-y, attention.
Il faut pas que ça s'effondre.
C'est pas mal.
-Non, c'est bien.
-Bravo.
-On a, en le renversant,
l'oeuf, du coup, qui trône
sur ce dôme de viande,
- en l'occurrence,
c'est du poulet et des crevettes -
et de riz blanc.
Merci pour cette recette insolite.
On a du "bol"
de le partager avec vous.
J'espère que c'est réciproque.
-Tout à fait.
-C'est comme ça que ça se présente,
dans les restaurants ?
-C'est exactement comme ça,
dans mes souvenirs d'enfance,
que ça se présente.
Il y a des légumes.
C'est important.
-Oui, pardon.
-J'insiste sur ça
parce qu'on a un repas complet.
C'est un repas...
Pardon de la comparaison,
mais c'est ma madeleine de Proust,
parce que c'est des souvenirs
où on était dans la cuisine,
avec mon père, ma mère,
qui cuisinaient beaucoup ensemble.
Vous voyez que le bol renversé,
il faut tout cuisiner à part.
C'était génial pour moi,
en tant qu'enfant,
de faire l'assemblage et de voir
qui l'avait le mieux assemblé
une fois renversé.
-Il est mieux renversé
chez vous que le mien.
Il y a des pousses de maïs,
il y a du bambou,
des carottes
et du chou pakchoï.
-Il y a des oignons.
-Exactement.
-Dites-nous une chose.
L'oeuf,
vous le mettez dans quel sens ?
Comment vous faites
pour faire cuire l'oeuf
et le mettre au fond du bol ?
-Il faut le faire glisser
dans le bol.
-A l'envers ?
-Le jaune doit être
au fond du bol.
-Et ça coule.
-Il faut pas que le jaune
soit crevé,
il faut faire très attention.
-C'est une belle technique.
Pour la petite histoire,
- parce qu'on trouve pas ça
partout dans Paris -
je l'ai vu aux Mascareignes,
dans le 11e.
C'est Roland Jundu, le chef,
qui a préparé ça ce matin pour nous.
Si vous aimez
cette recette,
elle est 202, boulevard Voltaire.
Vous pouvez déguster
un bol renversé.
Vous êtes une familière
de ce restaurant.
-Il y a plein de recettes
à découvrir, à partager.
Surtout, je conseille
à celles et ceux
qui veulent y aller :
prenez différents plats
et partagez.
C'est ce qu'on aime beaucoup faire.
Au secrétariat d'Etat,
c'est ce que j'ai dit
à mes équipes.
"On déjeune dans quelle brasserie ?"
J'ai dit : "Venez et prenez chacun
une assiette, un plat différent,
"on va partager
et vous allez pouvoir tout goûter."
On fait beaucoup ça à l'île Maurice.
On partage,
on n'est pas rivés sur son assiette.
-On cuisine beaucoup,
à l'île Maurice,
- vous disiez que vos parents
aimaient ça -
ou ça fait partie de la culture,
de partager ça ?
-Ca se retrouve
avec la culture française,
ce plaisir de se retrouver
autour d'un plat, ensemble,
chacun découvrant
les saveurs des autres.
Le bol renversé
a une origine asiatique,
mais est devenu un plat populaire
à l'île Maurice.
C'est pour ça
que ça permet la rencontre
des saveurs et des histoires.
-Goûtons ensemble.
-Vous nous donnez le feu vert ?
J'ai hâte de goûter.
-Allez.
-Dites-nous si ça correspond au goût
de votre enfance.
-Ca y ressemble.
-C'est difficile d'avoir
la même recette
et les mêmes souvenirs
que ceux de vos parents,
mais est-ce qu'on retrouve
ce goût-là ?
-C'est délicieux.
On a voyagé, là.
-L'oeuf est bien cuit.
Roland a bien fait
le boulot.
L'oeuf est pas dur,
le jaune va couler sur la viande.
Poulet et crevettes.
-Les petits légumes sont là.
-Et ça, vous le préparez
vous aussi pour vos enfants
aujourd'hui ?
Vous le faites régulièrement ?
-C'est quelque chose
qui est plaisant à faire.
On le fait ensemble, et après,
c'est celui qui va dire :
"T'as cassé ton oeuf."
"Il et pas bien..."
C'est génial.
C'est important de mettre
tous les différents aliments.
-Est-ce que c'est toujours
les mêmes aliments ?
Il y a avec du poulet,
avec des crevettes,
on mélange tout ça ?
-Vous pouvez faire
sans poulet et crevettes,
seulement avec des légumes.
-On peut faire végétarien.
Il y a plusieurs variantes.
-La logique reste la même,
du bol renversé,
mais on compose
son bol comme on veut.
On peut le faire végétarien.
-Roland me l'a dit.
Il fait ce plat,
mais vous pouvez faire ce plat
sur-mesure,
que des légumes,
des légumes français.
-Là, il rajoute,
- parce que c'est une recette
chinoise -
de la sauce d'huîtres,
de la sauce de soja,
de l'huile de sésame,
ce qui lui confère
ce goût un peu asiatique,
mais il peut être français.
-Pourquoi on retrouve
l'influence asiatique
dans ce plat mauricien ?
-Parce que l'île Maurice
est faite de sa diversité,
avec des influences
européennes, asiatiques,
africaines.
-Plus anglaises qu'asiatiques.
-Je vais parler
tout à l'heure des choses à savoir
sur la cuisine mauricienne.
-Au travers des étapes
de la colonisation,
qui ont été européennes,
mais effectivement,
il y a aussi
beaucoup de culture chinoise,
asiatique en général,
indienne, bien évidemment.
Toutes ces nuances,
toute cette diversité
ne s'effacent pas.
Elles permettent
de venir mettre en richesse
plein de choses au sein du pays,
car il y a quand même
le cadre national,
et à l'intérieur de ça,
la diversité
s'épanouit librement.
-C'est un plat populaire.
C'est un peu les restes du frigo ?
-Non, c'est pas les restes du frigo.
C'est vraiment un plat populaire
car on peut le faire rapidement,
on trouve facilement les aliments,
les aliments restent accessibles,
la recette peut évoluer,
mais c'est un plat
qui se fait simplement.
C'est pas les restes du frigo.
-Avec des restes du frigo,
on peut faire aussi
un bol renversé.
-Typiquement,
s'il reste du riz de la veille,
avec des légumes,
vous faites un bol renversé.
-Trois choses à savoir
sur la cuisine mauricienne.
-Vite fait,
car on en a un peu parlé.
La cuisine mauricienne
est un savoureux mélange
de traditions culinaires :
créole, chinoise, indienne,
africaine, française.
Sur l'île Maurice,
vous commencez par un croissant
au petit déj le matin,
un cari épicé,
un rougail de poisson
ou de saucisses au déjeuner,
et un biryani
ou des mines chinoises au dîner.
Vraiment, on a un a un vrai panel
de cuisine.
Autre trésor de la cuisine :
la street food, variée, abondante.
Impossible de visiter cette île
sans goûter au dholl puri,
m'a-t-on dit.
C'est l'équivalent
du jambon-beurre.
C'est une crêpe salée
à base de pois cassés,
que l'on trempe
dans une sauce,
incontournable
à l'île Maurice ?
-Oui, c'est la base.
-C'est le sandwich, un peu ?
On le mange dans la rue ?
-On le mange au marché.
On dit "le bazar", nous.
On part pas du marché
sans avoir mangé son dholl puri.
Dans votre journée,
vous avez oublié
le thé au lait.
-Oui, c'est vrai.
-On boit beaucoup de thé,
à l'île Maurice.
-La dernière spécialité
de cette île, c'est naturellement
les poissons et les fruits de mer :
poulpe, appelé ourite,
qu'on peut manger
en cari, aux épices,
les écrevisses d'eau douce,
et le marlin bleu,
sans arêtes,
un délicieux poisson
associé à une salade
de coeurs de palmier.
-On a fait le tour ?
-Il manque juste quelque chose,
c'est la traditionnelle bière
de l'île Maurice : la Phoenix.
Et ça, c'est aussi
un incontournable.
-Elle est brassée sur place ?
-Oui.
-La Phoenix, voilà.
-La Phoenix.
Sauf que là,
on a du vin blanc.
Vous vouliez qu'on accompagne
ce plat avec un vin d'Alsace,
un vin blanc sec
qui est un riesling.
Le riesling,
c'est le plus ancien cépage
d'Alsace,
c'est l'un des plus nobles
avec le gewurztraminer,
le pinot gris,
le muscat.
Ce vin blanc est une AOC,
évidemment.
Vous l'avez choisi
parce que vous êtes née
à Strasbourg ?
-Car je suis alsacienne.
Je suis d'origine mauricienne
par mes parents,
je suis née en Alsace
et aujourd'hui,
je suis en Ile-de-France.
C'est important de mêler traditions,
plaisirs du terroir, avec, aussi,
un gros plaisir de la table
en Alsace
qu'on retrouve.
C'est un vin
que j'apprécie énormément.
-Riesling, gewurztraminer
sylvaner, il y en a beaucoup.
-On a le choix.
On a le choix, en Alsace.
Il y a quand même
une très grande tradition
et un vignoble
très ancien, avec un héritage
extrêmement fort.
-Et une route des vins
magnifique,
si on veut se promener
du côté de Colmar ou des alentours.
-D'ailleurs, on arrive
sur les fêtes de fin d'année.
-C'est très festif, à Noël.
-Voilà. Le mois de décembre
est festif.
Il faut y aller,
il faut vraiment y aller.
-Vous avez ces souvenirs-là
en Alsace.
Vous y avez vécu ?
-Je n'ai pas vécu
en Alsace, j'y ai passé
mes deux premières années de vie.
Mes parents sont arrivés
en Ile-de-France,
mais mes parents s'y sont mariés
et y ont vécu
beaucoup plus longtemps
que deux ans. C'est vrai que,
quand mon père était encore vivant,
on retournait souvent à Strasbourg,
j'ai encore une tante
qui est à Strasbourg,
donc on est attachés
à Strasbourg.
-Et culinairement ?
Il y avait des choucroutes
à la maison, un certain nombre
de spécialités ?
-La choucroute, on ne la faisait pas
à la maison, mais oui,
on aime bien la choucroute,
mais quand on va à Strasbourg.
Ca fait partie des rituels.
C'est bien d'avoir
des petits rituels
et de se dire que c'est un moment
un peu à part, exclusif.
Oui, quand on va à Strasbourg,
il y a la forêt-noire,
il y a plein de choses.
-Vous aimez
parler de la cuisine,
on l'a bien compris, vous avez
une double racine.
Aux fourneaux,
vous aimez cuisiner ?
-On va être honnête deux secondes.
J'aime cuisiner mais en ce moment,
je n'ai pas le temps.
Par contre, j'ai un mari
qui adore ça
et qui arrive à prendre le temps.
Il cuisine très bien.
-Quand vous étiez aux fourneaux,
vous étiez plutôt Maurice
ou Strasbourg ?
-Plutôt Maurice.
-Oui, parce que c'est
ce qui me reste de mon enfance.
J'ai vu beaucoup mes parents,
on passait nos week-ends
dans la cuisine,
c'était vraiment le plaisir.
-Enfant,
c'était plutôt
de la cuisine mauricienne ?
-Il y avait de tout,
mais c'est vrai
que c'est les moments...
Dans la cuisine, je piquais de tout.
On me disait : 'Laisses-en un peu !"
Vraiment, on cuisinait de tout,
et encore aujourd'hui, c'est pareil.
Je peux aussi essayer,
de temps en temps, des recettes.
On aime bien voir comment ça prend.
On se trompe un peu
et on recommence. J'aime beaucoup.
-Pour les ingrédients, ça va ?
Il y a des ingrédients
plus rares,
qu'on ne trouve pas partout.
-Si, on trouve de tout.
-Ah oui ?
-Je ne vais pas dire
le nom du supermarché,
mais on en trouve
dans les hypers.
-Il y a tout
pour la cuisine chinoise
ou mauricienne ?
-Oui.
Vraiment.
Je vous donnerai
l'adresse.
Ce n'est pas loin d'ici.
-Il y a beaucoup
d'épices,
dans la cuisine mauricienne.
C'est quel genre d'épices ?
Il y en a
dans la cuisine africaine.
Ce n'est pas forcément les mêmes.
-Si,
mais elles ne sont pas utilisées
ou mélangées
de la même façon.
On a beaucoup, en base,
au-delà de ça,
l'ail et le gingembre
que l'on met partout.
Ca, c'est la base.
-Dans tous les plats ?
-Dès qu'on fait un sauté,
un rougail,
là, dans les légumes, il y en a,
une base de gingembre et d'ail.
Ensuite, toutes sortes d'épices
qu'on peut trouver.
C'est l'enjeu, aujourd'hui.
J'aime rappeler que l'épice
n'est pas forcément pimentée.
Il y a du piment,
mais tout n'est pas pimenté.
On pense ça.
-Oui, épicé, c'est parfumé.
Pimenté, c'est fort.
On a un piment, là.
Brigitte, moi, j'ai juste mis ça.
-La pointe de la fourchette.
-Juste ça.
-Et alors ?
-J'ai failli tousser
et m'évanouir.
-On ne va pas
vous faire goûter.
-J'adore.
D'une, j'adore, et je vais
vous faire une confidence,
car on est en confidence :
Un de mes ministres de tutelle,
Gabriel Attal,
adore aussi manger pimenté.
-Pour monsieur Attal.
-On lui en donnera,
on va vous faire un doggy bag.
-Il en a pour 10 ans, là !
-Non, non, il aime très pimenté.
-Le piment se mange
avec le bol renversé ?
Sur le dessus ?
-Le piment se mange avec tout.
-On en met dans tous les plats ?
-Oui, si on aime.
C'est vrai que...
-C'est épicé et pimenté ?
-Oui.
-C'est relevé.
-Le piment n'est jamais imposé
dans le plat,
toujours à côté.
Typiquement, les enfants,
on ne leur donne pas ça.
Ils ne peuvent pas le manger.
-On leur met à côté.
-Et chacun se sert.
Vraiment,
c'est le principe de la table
à l'île Maurice.
On met les plats et chacun se sert.
-Et mange comme il veut,
au rythme qu'il veut.
-Voilà,
ce qu'il veut,
car on peut avoir,
autour de la table,
des végétariens, etc.
Comme ça, tout le monde
est à l'aise,
il n'y a pas de plat unique,
chacun peut se servir.
-La tolérance
par rapport au piment,
une question car vous êtes des îles,
plus on en mange tôt,
plus on s'habitude,
ou est-ce qu'il y a des palais
qui sont faits pour ça ?
En France,
on n'en veut pas,
c'est trop fort.
-Pour être très transparente,
jusqu'à mes 30 ans,
je ne mangeais pas du tout pimenté.
-Votre palais
a évolué ?
-Je suis tombée enceinte,
j'ai perdu le goût,
je n'avais pas assez de goût,
et je cherchais
à avoir plus de saveurs.
C'est là que j'ai commencé
à manger pimenté, très pimenté.
-A Maurice,
tout le monde en mange ?
C'est habituel ?
Les palais
s'habituent ?
-On n'en mange pas
quand on est petits.
De manière naturelle
et évidente,
on ne donne pas du piment
à des enfants.
Après, ça se fait naturellement,
tout le monde
ne mange pas de piment,
mais il y en a sur la table.
-Est-ce qu'au ministère,
vous avez donné des consignes,
des recettes
pour manger mauricien ?
-Non, non.
On a une très bonne table,
avec, vraiment,
un plaisir d'être à table.
C'est très agréable,
mais quand j'ai envie de manger
mauricien,
ou un peu différent
de ce qui est proposé,
c'est aussi l'occasion
de dire aux équipes :
"On va s'aérer un peu."
Quand on est secrétaire d'Etat,
ministre,
on nous voit souvent dehors,
mais nos équipes
restent souvent au bureau.
C'est des occasions de sortir
et de découvrir d'autres choses,
en allant directement
mettre en avant nos restaurateurs.
-En me plongeant dans cette cuisine
mauricienne, il y a
des influences françaises.
On a parlé
des influences chinoises, indiennes,
mais j'ai lu qu'on mangeait
de la daube,
du chevreuil et du sanglier.
J'imaginais trois cocotiers
et des plages blanches.
On y mange du chevreuil ?
-Oui.
-Il y a des chasses,
des domaines ?
-Oui, il y a des domaines de chasse,
il y a des temps de chasse
qui s'ouvrent, bien évidemment.
C'est des moments attendus,
car ça fait partie de ces moments
où on se retrouve tous,
mais après, encore une fois,
personne n'est obligé,
personne n'est contraint,
mais c'est juste
le respect
des uns et des autres.
-C'était pour voir
la diversité de cette cuisine.
-Je vous le dis,
si on devait chercher
une devise pour l'île,
ça serait la diversité.
Toutes les nuances sont présentes,
et je le redis,
elles peuvent exister,
elles ne sont pas antagonistes,
car elles se rappellent
qu'elles sont dans un cadre
qui est le cadre de l'île,
avec une langue commune, le créole,
mais nous parlons aussi
anglais, français,
à la maison,
et ça ne choque personne.
On peut être à table,
parler français, puis, d'un coup,
changer car on dit
une blague,
et on la dit en créole,
car c'est plus drôle en créole,
et, d'un seul coup,
parler anglais, car il y a une news
qu'on aura lue en anglais,
donc on va la décrire en anglais.
Toute cette diversité,
aussi bien dans les visages
de l'île Maurice
que la gastronomie,
que les langues parlées,
que le paysage de l'île Maurice,
aussi,
témoignent de cette capacité
à non pas vivre ensemble,
mais faire ensemble.
-Il y a
toute cette diversité.
Vous mangez de tout,
ou est-ce qu'il y a des aliments
que vous n'aimez pas ?
-Je mange de tout.
-Vous mangez de tout.
-Je goûte toujours à tout.
C'est ce que je vous ai dit.
-Il n'y a rien que vous détestez ?
-En fait, si. Il y avait une chose
que je détestais étant petite,
le piment, parce que je n'avais pas
été habituée,
et les tomates cuites.
-Ah bon ?
-Souvent, les enfants
n'aiment pas
les tomates chaudes.
-Impossible.
En fait, à chaque fois, je reteste,
et maintenant, ça passe.
-Vous aimez ça.
-Je ne vais pas m'en faire
comme ça, mais il faut
toujours retester. Le palais évolue,
au long de la vie.
Parfois, il faut retester.
Ce n'est pas grave
si on n'aime pas,
on a goûté.
-C'est le message
que vous adressez aux enfants
et à la jeunesse.
-Je leur dis
de goûter.
J'ai la chance d'avoir
deux enfants qui goûtent tout,
mais je ne les oblige jamais.
S'ils n'aiment pas, OK,
mais ils goûtent.
-Alors, on voit
que les tendances évoluent aussi,
les goûts évoluent.
Est-ce que vous avez modifié
votre alimentation
tout au long des années ?
Est-ce que vous mangez
autant de viande qu'avant ?
Est-ce que votre alimentation
est différente ?
-Je mange moins de viande
qu'avant.,
C'est vrai,
je mangeais, que ce soit
de la viande blanche ou rouge,
une fois par jour,
sur un des repas.
-Enfant ?
-Enfant, ado,
et jeune adulte, en fait.
Depuis à peu près plus de 10 ans,
non,
je ne mange pas de la viande
tous les jours.
J'ai aussi fait évoluer
ma façon de manger,
au regard aussi des sociétés
dans lesquelles on évolue
et des informations
que nous avons,
de cette capacité
à dire qu'il y a des choses
qui ne sont pas mauvaises,
mais qui doivent être modérées,
et que l'alimentation
doit se regarder loin,
peut-être sur une échelle de temps
comme une semaine.
-C'est pour des questions
de santé,
écologiques, aussi ?
-Tout, tout.
Je le dis aussi,
j'ai beaucoup évolué
avec mes enfants.
Mes enfants m'ont ramené aussi
beaucoup de ces sujets
à la maison.
J'apprends énormément avec eux.
C'est agréable de dire
qu'on apprend avec nos enfants.
Evidemment,
la norme veut que ce soit
dans l'autre sens,
mais on apprend avec nos enfants.
J'ai grandi
avec des bouteilles d'eau
en plastique, à la maison.
-Oui.
-C'est une aberration.
C'est avec eux que j'ai évolué.
J'ai ma carafe remplie
à l'eau du robinet, c'est comme ça.
Je n'ai plus
de bouteilles en plastique.
J'ai un shampooing solide.
J'ai évolué, comme ça, beaucoup,
avec mes enfants.
-On va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollable :
c'est le quiz.
Musique tonique
-Prisca Thevenot,
vous êtes fan
de cuisine mauricienne.
Encore une fois,
merci de nous avoir partagé
ce bol renversé.
Sauriez-vous dire
si ces ingrédients, que l'on va voir
sur l'écran,
entre dans la recette
d'une autre spécialité mauricienne :
le fameux kalia de poulet ?
Est-ce qu'il y a
du yaourt nature
dans cette recette ?
-Oui.
-Bravo.
Est-ce qu'il y a
des oeufs durs ?
(-Dans le kalia...)
Euh... J'aurais dit non.
-Il y a des oeufs durs.
-Ah oui ?
-Est-ce qu'il y a
de l'anis étoilé ?
-Oui, la badiane.
-Est-ce qu'il y a de l'aneth ?
-Non.
-Voilà. Pas mal, bien, même.
-Très bien !
L'île Maurice est aussi
l'un des rares pays
à avoir sur son sol
une vanille de qualité.
Sauriez-vous nous dire
quel est le pays
qui ne produit pas
cette gousse divine ?
Elle lit les diverses propositions.
...
Dans quel pays on ne trouve pas
de vanille ?
-La Grèce ?
-La Grèce, exactement.
On en trouve au Sri Lanka,
en Ouganda et au Mexique,
ce qui est quand même...
-Le Sri Lanka, ça va,
mais ce qui m'a étonné,
c'est l'Ouganda, mais oui,
il y a de la vanille en Ouganda
et au Mexique.
-Et à l'île Maurice.
-Vous mangez
beaucoup de vanille ?
Vous aimez ?
-J'en mets dans le sucre.
Je la fends en deux
et je la mets,
ça le parfume, c'est génial.
-C'est autour de la table
que se nouent les deals politiques,
que se fait l'histoire.
C'est la brève de comptoir.
On vous a demandé de nous raconter
une petite histoire,
une petite anecdote politique
autour d'un repas.
Est-ce qu'il y a une histoire
qui vous est revenue ?
-Une histoire qui m'est revenue
à l'esprit,
c'était avec mon grand,
mon fils Paul, qui a neuf ans
aujourd'hui.
On était à table,
j'étais parlementaire.
J'étais rentrée pendant la pause,
pour dîner avec eux.
J'étais préoccupée.
J'étais avec eux,
mais je n'étais pas là.
J'étais en train de penser
à l'hémicycle,
ce qui peut arriver souvent,
je le reconnais.
Cette fois-ci,
j'étais assise en face de lui,
mon petit était sur le côté,
et il me dit :
"A quoi tu penses ?
Fallait pas revenir."
Il avait raison. Du coup...
-"Je m'en vais !"
-Je lui raconte :
"Il s'est passé ça et ça.
"Tu te rends compte,
c'est dur, ce sujet."
Je n'ai pas des mots d'enfant,
je le dis comme je l'ai vécu
dans la journée,
il peut comprendre sans dramatiser.
C'était un sujet qui avait eu lieu
sur la binationalité,
dans l'hémicycle, porté par
une certaine partie de l'hémicycle.
Je lui dis :
"Ca me pose problème, imagine,
"on fait comment ?
"Maman, elle fait comment ?"
Il me regarde, il me dit :
"Je ne vois pas
pourquoi ça t'embête,
"prends des forces et retournes-y."
-Ca donne du courage.
-Je me suis dit : "Oui."
Il m'a dit :
"Tu t'es engagée en politique..."
Il m'a dit : "Tu t'es engagée
avec Emmanuel Macron
"pour que ça change."
Vraiment,
c'était : "Respecte ce temps
de repas qu'on vit ensemble."
Ce n'est pas
super drôle,
mais je trouve
que c'est très symbolique aussi.
Peut-être apprendre, nous,
de temps à temps, à déconnecter,
à couper, et à profiter
du moment.
-C'est difficile, en politique.
-Dans la vie de tous les jours,
pas qu'en politique.
-On est absorbés
par son travail,
on a du mal
à écouter les autres.
Cette anecdote
revient en permanence
dans votre tête ?
-Il faut qu'on...
Peu importe ce qu'on peut mettre
dans son assiette,
il faut qu'on soit capables
d'apprécier le moment présent.
-Du coup, est-ce que
vous avez changé ? Est-ce que,
quand vous êtes à table,
vous vous dites :
"Ca reste dehors,
"c'est le temps du repas,
"c'est un temps familial
que je leur consacre" ?
-Oui.
-Vous arrivez à déconnecter ?
-Oui, je le fais vraiment.
On parle de tout et de rien,
et c'est génial.
C'est génial, et ça permet aussi
de respirer.
Ca fait une respiration.
-Ils s'intéressent
à la politique, vos enfants ?
-Ils n'ont pas eu le choix,
je crois.
J'ai commencé à m'engager
avec, effectivement,
le président de la République,
alors candidat,
le grand avait 2 ans et demi
et le petit
venait juste de naître.
Je me souviens qu'à l'époque,
avec Laurent Saint-Martin,
on mettait les tracts
sous la poussette.
C''était pratique, ils dormaient.
-Il y a
un petit espace.
-Pour faire dormir un enfant,
on promenait la poussette
et c'était génial.
Ils ont toujours été là,
je les emmenais.
-Ils tractaient jeunes.
-Ils n'ont pas tracté.
Aux réunions publiques,
s'ils voulaient venir, ils venaient,
ils étaient dans un coin.
Sans réellement participer,
ils voient ce que c'est, oui.
-Ca leur donne envie de faire
de la politique,
ou, au contraire, ça les...
-Ils verront.
Déjà,
qu'ils apprennent à l'école.
Après, ils auront tout le temps
de venir voir.
-On va parler d'un sujet politique :
l'inflation alimentaire,
qui plonge les jeunes
dans la précarité.
Peut-on conserver
une alimentation équilibrée ?
Le dessous des plats.
...
Après un pic de 16 % en mars,
l'inflation alimentaire devrait
refluer à 7 % en décembre.
Cette hausse des prix oblige
des étudiants
à se rendre
dans des collectes alimentaires.
Clément Perrouault
et Marion Devauchelle
ont suivi Mélissa
à l'université de Villetaneuse,
en Seine-Saint-Denis.
-Ils sont les visages
de la précarité étudiante.
Ce jour-là, la collecte alimentaire
sur le campus a enregistré
150 bénéficiaires.
Dans la queue,
de nombreux étrangers,
comme Mélissa, algérienne.
-Je n'ai pas
de bourse, du coup,
je dois travailler pour subvenir
à mes besoins.
Mon salaire,
c'est entre 400 et 500 euros.
Je paye mon loyer 364 euros.
Du coup, c'est peu
pour acheter autre chose.
Normalement, j'ai un TD,
mais je ne suis pas partie
juste pour prendre
de quoi manger,
donc ça influence sur mes études.
-Pour éviter de rater trop de cours
à cause des collectes,
Mélissa s'est organisée
avec ses copines.
-C'est pour trois personnes,
pour moi et deux autres.
-Ils sont tous inscrits ?
-Oui.
Après, des fois,
c'est elles qui viennent.
On s'organise,
ça dépend des jours.
-Mélissa fait le plein
de produits d'hygiène...
-Merci, bon courage.
-...de conserves
et de fruits et légumes.
-Merci !
-Bonjour !
-Bonjour,
c'est pour trois personnes.
-OK. Deux, trois.
-Merci !
-De rien !
-De quoi se préparer
un repas équilibré.
-Bonne journée !
-Peut-être
des salades de fruits,
ça fait du bien.
Les légumes,
faire des gratins aux légumes,
ou des soupes aussi,
c'est important, car il fait froid.
Pour les fruits et légumes,
c'est même pas une semaine.
Pour d'autres choses, ça tient.
C'est déjà ça.
Sinon,
il y a d'autres distributions.
On va chaque mercredi,
des fois, samedi, dans d'autres
associations.
Il faudra
le rajouter dans son planning.
-La collecte ce jour-là
est organisée
par l'Union Etudiante,
un syndicat de gauche
qui dénonce une envolée
de la précarité dans les campus.
-Tous les prix
ont tellement augmenté
pour les denrées de base
qu'il y a des difficultés
des étudiants
à se nourrir.
-Qu'est-ce qui pèse sur le budget ?
-C'est surtout les produits
d'hygiène les plus chers,
mais ça va être également
l'habillement,
ça va être l'alimentation.
La principale chose,
c'est le logement.
-A la fin de la collecte,
750 kilos de denrées
ont été distribuées.
-Vous avez entendu Mélissa.
Elle est obligée
de rater les cours
pour pouvoir
se nourrir, pour aller chercher
de la nourriture
pour elle et ses amies,
pour pouvoir manger. C'est normal,
aujourd'hui, en France ?
-Vous avez déjà la réponse
dans votre question.
L'enjeu que nous avons,
en tant que politiques,
responsables politiques,
c'est de ne pas nier les difficultés
que nos jeunes
et moins jeunes rencontrent
au quotidien,
du fait de l'inflation
et d'autres enjeux encore.
Nous avons répondu
avec différents dispositifs
sur l'inflation.
Je vais pas les rappeler ici
parce que ce n'est pas l'objet,
mais nous devons
continuer à le faire,
et nous avons par exemple travaillé,
- on parlait des étudiants -
et le représentant syndical
le disait à juste titre...
Il a fallu faire évoluer
certains dispositifs qui existaient
et qui n'étaient plus
en adéquation
avec le contexte
économique et financier
tel qu'on le connaît.
C'est pas moi,
ni le gouvernement
qui y avons réfléchi
depuis nos bureaux,
mais c'est issu d'un échange
entre le président lui-même
et des jeunes qui lui avaient dit :
"Nous ne pouvons pas accéder
"au système de bourses."
-Donc ça veut dire
étendre le système de bourses fait
pour une partie des étudiants ?
-C'est pour ça qu'on l'a réformé,
on l'a fait évoluer,
avec ma collègue
Sylvie Retailleau,
qui a pu le mettre en place
dès cette rentrée-là.
Concrètement, c'est quoi ?
C'est 35 000 étudiants
qui ne pouvaient pas être boursiers,
qui, avec une situation
identique,
aujourd'hui,
sont devenus boursiers.
-Comme Mélissa.
Elle est pas boursière.
-Il faut déjà
rappeler ça parce qu'il y a
aussi un problème...
-35 000.
-35 000
qui sont devenus boursiers...
-A l'échelle de la population
étudiante, c'est pas énorme,
non plus.
-Et 140 000 étaient
déjà boursiers
et ont eu une revalorisation
sans avoir de changement
de situation.
Tous les étudiants ne sont pas
boursiers, et c'est heureux.
On doit cibler ces aides
sur ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin.
C'est le principe.
Maintenant,
il faut regarder
dans sa globalité.
Il y a de nombreuses associations
qui sont aussi sur le terrain
pour voir des profils
comme Mélissa.
Là aussi, nous les aidons
car je suis secrétaire d'Etat
à la Jeunesse, au SNU,
et à la Vie associative.
-Il y a beaucoup de jeunes
qui vous disent
que c'est difficile
de manger, de se loger,
et donc, de travailler ?
-Bien évidemment.
Depuis que je suis au secrétariat
d'Etat à la Jeunesse,
ça fait 3 mois à peu près,
mon premier point
a été de surtout pas
m'installer dans le bureau
et de très vite
aller en région,
pour pouvoir
parler aux jeunes partout.
L'enjeu, c'était pas
qu'ils m'écoutent,
mais qu'on puisse
échanger.
-Apporter des solutions.
-Oui, donc, sans caméras,
sans médias,
je préfère le dire.
C'est pas que je ne veux pas,
mais les échanges
sont pas les mêmes
et on parle de sujets
qui touchent beaucoup
à la sensibilité de chacun.
C'est pas facile.
Ca nous permet aussi
d'adapter
nos politiques publiques.
On fait des réformes
concrètes.
Quand je parle de 35 000
boursiers de plus
ou de 140 000 qui ont vu
leur bourse augmenter...
Mais il faut aussi
qu'on puisse voir
où il y a encore
des choses à ajuster.
-Ce que dit Mélissa,
c'est que le logement
prend une grande partie
de ce qu'elle a, en fait,
de l'argent
qu'elle peut avoir.
-Oui.
-Ca empiète sur l'alimentation.
Est-ce que,
sur le logement étudiant,
on peut faire un effort ?
-Des choses
ont déjà été faites,
notamment par ma collègue
Sylvie Retailleau.
Je préfère la nommer
pour rendre hommage à son travail,
notamment sur le Crous,
avec le sujet
des repas à 1 euro
ou 3,30 euros.
1 euro, c'est...
-Le tarif social ou les boursiers.
-C'est si on est boursier
ou si on est en situation
de fragilité.
Mais c'est aussi le gel
des loyers au niveau du Crous.
Le sujet du logement
doit se voir
de façon plus générale.
Et là, je me réfère aussi
à mon autre collègue,
Patrice Vergriete,
qui travaille sur ces enjeux.
Mais il faut être très clair,
ça ne sera pas
la mesure phare.
C'est quelque chose d'assez long
qu'on doit pouvoir engager,
mais on doit pouvoir apporter
des réponses immédiates
et variées.
C'est en ça que vous voyez...
Je vous parle de la jeunesse,
d'autres collègues
parce que mon enjeu aussi,
c'est d'être ce ministère
du lien des jeunes entre eux,
des jeunes avec la société,
avec le monde associatif,
mais moi aussi,
du lien que je fais
avec mes collègues.
Je ne peux pas parler
de la jeunesse toute seule.
Je le fais aussi
avec mes ministres de tutelle,
Gabriel Attal, Sébastien Lecornu,
et le gouvernement.
-Ces repas 1 euro...
Le président avait annoncé
deux repas à 1 euro.
Est-ce que ça,
ça va perdurer ?
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui,
on peut,
midi et soir,
quand on est boursier,
manger pour 1 euro ?
Est-ce que ces repas à 1 euro
pourraient concerner
tous les étudiants ?
On se souvient
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale,
la gauche l'a proposé,
la majorité l'a refusé.
Est-ce que ce n'est pas
une erreur, finalement ?
-Alors, voilà tout le sujet...
Merci de poser la question.
Déjà, rappelons que la création
du repas à 1 euro,
- j'aime pas faire ça,
mais il va falloir remettre
les pendules à l'heure -,
c'est le président
de la République
qui l'a mis en place
au lendemain de la crise Covid.
Nous l'avons créé.
Je n'ai entendu personne expliquer
qu'il fallait le créer
jusque-là.
Et nous l'avons pérennisé.
Ca devait être un dispositif
dans une durée de temps
limitée,
et nous l'avons pérennisé
sur, et j'étais encore députée,
le projet de loi de finances
de l'année dernière
que toutes les oppositions,
et notamment cette gauche,
a refusé de voter.
Quand ils refusent
de voter le budget de finances,
les textes financiers,
ils refusent de mettre en place
ces dispositifs qu'après,
ils viennent, de façon démagogique,
nous reproposer sans avoir
les crédits derrière.
Ensuite, sur le sujet
du 1 euro pour tous...
La question, c'est :
c'est bien de le décréter,
mais est-ce que c'est possible ?
Est-ce que nous avons
les capacités
en termes de Crous,
d'infrastructures,
pour le faire ?
Ensuite,
est-ce que notre enjeu,
ce n'est pas de cibler
les aides
pour celles et ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin ?
Je le dis de façon claire.
Les fonds de l'Etat,
les deniers publics,
c'est l'argent des Français,
et ce n'est pas illimité.
Donc, cette proposition de loi
qui avait été portée
par Louis Boyard,
j'étais encore députée,
à toutes ces questions-là,
il n'y avait pas de réponse.
-Mais les jeunes sont
parfois en rupture
avec leur famille.
C'est pas parce que les parents
gagnent assez d'argent
pour que le jeune
ne soit pas boursier,
que forcément, il pourra demander
de l'argent à ses parents.
Enfin, ils ont aussi envie
d'être autonomes...
Et le gouvernement a refusé
l'allocation pour les jeunes
ou le revenu universel.
Le président en a encore
parlé, récemment.
-Mais de quoi on parle ?
C'est deux visions de société
qui sont différentes.
Notre enjeu depuis 2007,
c'est d'être dans l'émancipation
et la capacité pour un jeune
d'être maître de son destin.
Ca ne veut pas dire qu'il va
se débrouiller tout seul.
On va l'accompagner,
mettre des dispositifs en place
pour qu'il n'ait pas
à se sentir...
C'est pas moi qui le dis,
c'est les jeunes que j'ai vus
en Creuse, à La Réunion,
à Bordeaux ou à Lyon.
Ils ne veulent pas être administrés,
mais être
responsabilisés.
Donc nous devons leur donner
les capacités
de le faire aujourd'hui,
donc au travers de l'école,
des enseignements supérieurs
avec le système de bourses
qui évolue,
la lutte contre la précarité
menstruelle.
C'est un coût,
pour les jeunes filles
dont on a peu parlé
jusqu'à présent.
-Ca va passer dans le budget
de la Sécurité sociale.
-Et il est temps !
C'était un tabou
parce que ça ne concernait
que les jeunes filles.
Tout ça, on doit pouvoir
le regarder
de façon assez claire,
mais sans démagogie,
sans démagogie.
Et le sujet
de l'aide universelle...
de l'aide universelle,
la question c'est...
Les jeunes veulent surtout
travailler,
trouver le bon emploi,
bien payé,
C'est ça l'enjeu, aujourd'hui.
-Alors, vous parliez
de Louis Boyard.
J'ai vu un échange
assez drôle sur Twitter.
Louis Bayard a tweeté hier :
"La ministre de la Jeunesse
"m'a invité à venir visiter
un SNU avec elle.
"Je lui ai dit d'accord,
"à condition qu'elle visite
"une distribution
alimentaire avec moi.
"Elle ne m'a pas répondu.
"Je lui demande ici :
on organise ça quand ?"
C'est lui qui le dit,
pas moi.
-Alors, Louis Boyard
est quand même assez...
génial,
pour pas dire autre chose.
En fait, c'est l'homme
de la capsule et du challenge,
c'est-à-dire qu'en permanence,
il est là pour faire du buzz,
pour faire parler de lui.
-Ca marche.
-Ca fait pas avancer les choses ?
-C'est pas sa responsabilité.
-Ca fait pas bouger les choses ?
On parle pas
de ces sujets-là ?
-Là, c'est d'une hypocrisie
sans nom.
En plus, je lui ai répondu.
En audition,
on parlait justement
des budgets
alloués à la jeunesse.
Louis Boyard est venu
pour faire sa capsule,
il m'a fait une grande leçon,
une grande litanie sur le respect,
Je lui ai dit : "C'est gentil
de me parler de respect,
"mais regarde
comment tu te comportes."
Et charité bien ordonnée
commence par soi-même.
Je lui ai dit :
"Tu parles du SNU,
viens voir ce que c'est."
-Est-ce que vous allez aller
dans une collecte...
-Il m'a mis une condition.
Je lui ai dit :
"Toute proposition..."
Il m'a pas répondu
pour le SNU
mais il m'a mis
une condition en me disant :
"Venez échanger avec des jeunes.
De toute façon,
dès qu'on me proposera d'échanger
avec des jeunes, je viendrai.
-Donc vous dites oui.
-Mais vous plaisantez ?
Je lui ai répondu
en audition, oui.
Mais il avait fait sa capsule
et n'a pas écouté la réponse.
-C'était le buzz pour le buzz ?
Vous êtes sûre de ça ?
-Je lui ai répondu après,
j'ai capsulé.
J'ai fait la même chose.
C'est dommage,
je voulais pas le faire.
Je pensais qu'il allait
dire que j'avais répondu, etc.
Pas du tout
et c'était très désobligeant
pour ses collègues
qui ne savaient pas quoi dire,
parce qu'il ne m'a pas
répondu.
-On parlait de la précarité,
pas seulement alimentaire.
Vous la voyez ?
Vous la percevez
chez ces jeunes du SNU
que vous essayez
de faire vivre ensemble ?
-Mais les fragilités existent,
qu'elles soient d'ordre
alimentaire, familial,
psychologique...
et sur plein d'autres sujets
qui les traversent.
-Le SNU, c'est une réponse ?
-Ce n'est pas l'alpha
et l'oméga des réponses
à apporter.
C'est pas l'objet.
L'objet,
c'est aussi de répondre
à un enjeu, aujourd'hui,
de cohésion
nationale.
Je vous parlais de l'île Maurice.
On a besoin aussi de savoir
qu'on est dans la même équipe.
Je le dis
d'autant plus
qu'on est en année olympique.
Eh bien, rappelons-nous
qu'on est dans la même équipe,
qu'il faut provoquer des échanges,
des rencontres avec des jeunes.
C'est ça, le SNU,
pas simplement se rencontrer
mais se rencontrer en faisant,
avec des associations locales,
sur un tas de sujets
que les jeunes
nous adressent eux-mêmes :
sur le harcèlement,
sur le lien police-population,
sur l'environnement
et la biodiversité.
C'est apprendre à se rencontrer
et à se connaître en faisant.
-Faut-il rendre obligatoire ce SNU ?
On a vu que vous aviez parfois
des prises de parole
contradictoires.
Faut-il le généraliser
et le rendre obligatoire ?
-Elles sont absolument pas
contradictoires.
Mais j'ai bien fait
d'avoir une deuxième explication,
parce que souvent
on considère que Twitter
est l'alpha et l'oméga
de la communication.
C'est des capsules
de 2 minutes 20
sur une interview de 30 minutes,
on peut
ne pas se rendre compte
de l'entièreté du propos.
Ce que je dis, c'est qu'avant
de parler d'obligation,
il faut faire l'explication du SNU.
Beaucoup de gens
n'ont pas compris
ce qu'était le SNU.
Par exemple, j'étais à La Courneuve
il y a 2 ou 3 semaines
avec des jeunes, et la première,
pas des questions,
mais des interpellations, a été :
"J'ai pas envie de faire le SNU."
Je dis "Très bien,
mais qu'est-ce que le SNU" ?
Et là...
-"J'en sais rien."
Je dis : "Très bien,
"on va en parler."
"C'est 22 jours
dans un camp militaire."
Je dis : "Pas du tout."
-On parle
d'un service militaire déguisé.
-C'est ni une colonne, ni l'armée.
Et regarder le drapeau se lever
et chanter
"la Marseillaise",
c'est pas être militaire,
c'est être français.
Rappelons les symboles
de la République
pour les remettre
à leur juste place.
J'ai expliqué pour qu'après
il me dise s'il avait envie ou pas.
Il a pas répondu.
-Mais ça veut dire qu'en 2024...
Pardon, Jean-Pierre,
mais en 2024,
ce sera pour toute une classe d'âge.
-Depuis 2019, quand ça a été lancé
par Gabriel Attal,
entre 2019 et maintenant,
90 000 jeunes l'ont fait.
On va rentrer sur une phase
d'accélération
puisque rien que sur l'année 2024,
80 000 jeunes vont le faire.
Il y a un dispositif SNU
tel qu'on le connaît,
c'est hors temps scolaire,
et maintenant le SNU va rentrer
dans le temps scolaire.
-Donc pour tous les enfants ?
-Et donc, tous les jeunes...
C'est toujours sur la base
du volontariat,
je vous le dis de façon claire
pour peut-être lever des tabous.
Sur le mois de juillet
de cette année,
17 000 jeunes sont partis
en séjour de cohésion SNU,
c'est 127 centres
ouverts en simultané.
Il y en a 5000 qui n'ont pas pu
y aller parce qu'on n'avait pas
assez de places disponibles.
On a des jeunes
qui veulent faire le SNU,
donc notre enjeu,
c'est cette montée
en puissance,
cette montée
de façon très forte
en généralisation,
mais il faut le faire aussi
en cadence au regard
de la mécanique
à mettre en place.
L'année prochaine, nous continuerons
cette montée en puissance du SNU.
-On va parler
d'un autre sujet
qui concerne la jeunesse
et qui touche beaucoup nos jeunes,
le surpoids.
Comment en parler ?
Existe-t-il
des recettes miracles ?
On met les pieds dans le plat.
-Oui, Brigitte,
c'est un fléau qui connaît
une forte augmentation
chez les jeunes de 18 à 24 ans,
l'obésité.
Lucie, 18 ans,
habite près de Vichy. Pour perdre
ses kilos en trop,
elle a parié sur une méthode
qui mêle ateliers
et nouvelles habitudes alimentaires,
un reportage
de Dario Borgogno et André Lafont.
-Lucie pesait presque 100 kilos.
Depuis cette photo,
elle en a perdu 20.
Même avec le soutien
de son compagnon,
ces souvenirs
restent douloureux.
-On voit que j'essaie de me trouver
une robe à ma taille,
mais en fait ça me va pas du tout
puisque je me trouve
vraiment immonde.
-A cause de son obésité,
elle subit des moqueries.
-Durant toute la primaire
et au début du collège,
je me suis fait harceler
parce que je n'étais pas
dans les normes.
J'étais beaucoup enveloppée,
je faisais beaucoup de...
Beaucoup de kilos.
J'ai fait une phobie scolaire
à cause de ça,
j'ai arrêté de me nourrir
parce que du coup,
ça me détruisait, en fait.
Le fait d'avoir des remarques
tous les jours,
on a plus envie de manger, on se dit
que se laisser mourir de faim
marchera peut-être.
-Pour s'en sortir,
Lucie suit
depuis 2 ans un programme gratuit
à domicile
avec des professionnels de santé,
basé sur des jeux de rôles.
-Je vous annonce que là,
tout de suite,
Lucie est anxieuse.
Alors de quoi elle aurait besoin
à ce moment-là ?
Papa dit : "J'aurais besoin
d'être comprise."
-Oui.
-Ah, bien.
-En discutant avec les parents,
les enfants,
on va réfléchir à ce qu'on pourrait
modifier dans le quotidien
pour prendre en charge
ces questions
d'obésité
et de surpoids.
-Mieux communiquer
mais aussi mieux se nourrir.
Proxob apprend aux adolescents
à rééquilibrer leurs repas.
-Et au niveau des quantités ?
Féculents ?
Je réduis les féculents
en ce moment,
donc je prends qu'une louche
et j'augmente les légumes.
Ca, c'est à volonté
et c'est ce qui permet
de maigrir le plus.
-Une petite révolution culinaire
pour la famille.
-On mange mieux et on mange
en plus petites quantités,
puisqu'on sait maintenant
quand on a faim.
-Avant, les assiettes,
il fallait finir.
Maintenant,
c'est pas grave.
-Plus de sodas à table,
moins de chocolat
et plus de fruits.
Lucie suit les conseils de Proxob
pour ne plus, comme elle le dit,
manger ses émotions.
Résultat : de meilleurs plats
et un esprit apaisé.
-Déjà, même sans compter
physiquement,
mais le regard envers elle-même,
elle s'estime mieux.
Et pour moi, c'est important
que ma fille se sente bien.
-Proxob a déjà aidé
plus de 300 familles
en Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
et espère à présent
se généraliser
sur toute la France.
-Que pensez-vous de l'efficacité
de ces programmes ?
Plus malin que des régimes
purs et durs
ou gadgets ?
-Vous le voyez
très justement
avec cette jeune fille
qui a le sourire aux lèvres,
qui en plus met des mots
sur ce qu'elle ressentait,
qui en parle librement
et qui n'a pas honte de dire
ce qu'elle ressent.
Et je trouve ça
extrêmement puissant.
Elle fait vivre ça
à sa famille.
Elle ne vit pas toute seule,
elle le partage.
Et c'est des moments
de convivialité,
peut-être de redécouverte
de certains liens familiaux.
-Le but, c'est perde des kilos.
-Pas juste qu'elle perde des kilos,
le but,
c'est qu'elle se sente bien
et c'est ça qui est important.
Elle le disait dans le reportage,
elle mangeait ses émotions.
Elle doit pouvoir parler
de ses émotions
et il n'y a rien de mieux.
Elle peut perdre des kilos
et se sentir toujours aussi mal.
-C'est votre préoccupation,
en lien avec la Santé ?
-Oui.
C'est une préoccupation
du ministère,
de l'entièreté du gouvernement,
et c'est surtout une difficulté
que les jeunes nous disent.
Il y a un sujet de surpoids,
d'obésité,
et aussi un sujet
de troubles alimentaires
qui s'est amplifié
après la crise Covid.
-Anorexie
et boulimie.
-Evidemment.
Il faut qu'on soit en capacité
d'entendre la parole
et de la provoquer,
de pas simplement dire
"Salut, comment tu vas ?"
mais d'entendre la réponse
et d'être en capacité
d'entendre une réponse
qui serait négative.
Ca peut faire mal
quand son enfant va mal.
Il faut le dire franchement,
mais il faut qu'on puisse aussi
être accompagné.
C'est aussi
tout un environnement familial
qu'il faut embarquer.
Toute la famille
est concernée.
-On a l'impression qu'on est restés
à "mangez cinq fruits et légumes".
On peut pas aller au-delà ?
-Bien sûr que si.
Il faut aller au-delà.
Il faut lutter
contre la sédentarité.
Ca, c'est très simple.
Il faut se créer des réflexes.
Il faut qu'on redevienne
cette nation sportive, comme dit
ma collègue Amélie Oudéa-Castéra.
30 minutes de sport par jour,
à l'école, ça se fait.
Moi, je le vois.
-Ca, c'est mis en place ?
-J'ai deux enfants.
Je le vois.
-On m'a dit qu'ils n'étaient
même pas en survêtement.
-Le temps de se changer
et de se rechanger.
-On le fait
avec une chemise ?
-Qu'est-ce que 30 minutes
de sport par jour ?
C'est aussi se dépenser,
aller marcher, voilà.
On n'a pas besoin d'être
dans une salle de sport.
-Donc c'est de l'activité.
-C'est de l'activité.
-Le sport,
y a un côté performance.
-Vous avez raison.
C'est de l'activité physique.
Vous avez raison de me reprendre.
On n'est pas obligé
d'être dans une salle de sport.
Et donc ça, nos jeunes
prennent le réflexe
et vont le garder,
ce réflexe du sport.
Ils vont bouger,
proposer des choses, être dehors
et puis être en groupe,
en cohésion.
-C'est bien
pour le mental ?
-Oui.
C'est bien pour tout.
Et il y a aussi
la capacité,
comme disait Lucie
dans votre reportage,
de comprendre
ce qu'est une alimentation
saine et diversifiée.
Et ça, c'est bien de le dire,
mais il faut aussi l'expliquer.
Eh bien, il y a tous ces sujets
qui sont travaillés à l'école.
-C'est le rôle de l'école
ou c'est plutôt
le rôle des parents ?
-Moi, j'aime pas parler d'élèves.
Je parle de jeunes ou d'enfants.
Vous allez comprendre
la logique de la continuité
pédagogique.
La pédagogie ne s'arrête pas
aux portes de l'école.
Nous sommes tous responsables
en tant qu'adultes,
ceux qui évoluent
autour de nos enfants,
qu'on soit parent,
proche direct,
ou simplement
dans nos entourages proches,
bien évidemment
le monde éducatif,
responsables.
Nous avons cette responsabilité
d'apprentissage,
d'autorité sur les jeunes.
C'est pour ça qu'il faut
pouvoir parler
d'enfants et de jeunes,
parce que tout au long
de sa journée,
de sa semaine,
le jeune continue à apprendre
et je le disais,
on apprend beaucoup d'eux.
-Vous parlez
de l'école
qui va éduquer les élèves
sur la malbouffe,
mais les industriels
qui font des produits
trop sucrés, trop gras,
quasiment addictifs,
il faut pas un peu parfois
mettre le holà,
faire des seuils de sucre
dans certains produits,
éviter
des produits addictifs
qui font qu'on mange
beaucoup de barres chocolatées
dans la journée ?
Il y a pas des mesures
à prendre vers les industriels
de l'agroalimentaire ?
-Vous faites le lien
avec toute l'action
qui est menée par ma collègue
Olivia Grégoire,
justement sur ça,
surtout dans le pays
de la gastronomie.
Encore une fois,
quand on dit gastronomie,
on a l'impression
tout de suite
que ça va être très cher
avec des produits luxueux.
Pas du tout.
La gastronomie française
est une gastronomie
accessible,
qui s'adapte aux saisons.
-Olivia Grégoire,
c'est sur le fait maison,
pour éviter les produits
industriels.
-C'est important aussi
de rappeler
le fait maison.
Je suis pas en train
d'opposer l'industriel
avec le tout fait maison.
Il faut qu'on puisse
être en harmonie
et décomplexer les choses.
On peut parfois se faire un burger
dans un fast-food ou une pizza,
c'est pas grave, on est pas
une mauvaise personne.
L'alimentation ne doit pas,
en revanche,
être que ça.
Ca peut être des moments de plaisir,
comme de cuisiner
en famille,
de se retrouver entre amis.
Là, je vois le dessert
qui est arrivé...
-Oui, vous le regardez.
-Oui, depuis tout à l'heure.
-Il est fait maison.
Brigitte, j'ai vu
un chiffre dingue
sur les papiers sortis
après le travail
d'Olivia Grégoire.
Moins de 10 % des restaurants
en France font 100 %
du fait maison.
C'est dingue, moins de 10 %.
-C'est pour ça
qu'il faut pouvoir le faire.
Le fait maison,
c'est à la maison aussi.
C'est aussi important.
En plus de partager ce moment
à table,
c'est aussi
partager ce moment
dans la cuisine
à faire ensemble.
-Vous regardez
le dessert.
On y passe tout de suite
et c'est Le péché mignon.
-Avec un crumble. Le crumble
a été créé au Royaume-Uni
pendant la Deuxième Guerre,
alors que sévissait
un rationnement
des ingrédients
nécessaires pour faire
des gâteaux : le beurre,
la farine, le sucre...
Le crumble est
un gâteau de crise.
On mettait des fruits pas trop chers
trouvés dans le verger.
Comme on avait peu de beurre,
de sucre, de farine...
-On émiettait ?
-On émiettait un peu de pâte
au-dessus.
On pouvait pas faire
une vraie pâte à tarte,
donc on la mettait dessus.
C'est devenu le crumble,
qui veut dire "émietté"
en anglais.
C'est votre dessert favori ?
C'est un peu le bol renversé.
-J'aime bien le crumble,
parce que c'est facile à faire,
avec des produits
qu'on trouve assez rapidement,
pas très onéreux,
et puis aussi,
ça me rappelle...
J'en faisais
quand j'étais étudiante.
Je vivais en colocation.
On pouvait le faire
en grand plat
pour tout le monde,
pour pas très cher
et on était très contents,
parce qu'on le partageait.
Je me souviens,
on se le partageait
directement
dans le plat.
-Pas toujours aux pommes ?
-Si, toujours.
-Il y a des variantes.
On peut
en trouver avec tous les fruits.
-Il y en a même
avec du chocolat...
Non, crumble aux pommes.
Je suis très classique.
-Et le crumble salé ?
Vous avez essayé
avec des légumes ?
-Si, j'ai déjà goûté, mais moi,
je suis très classique.
-Vous, c'est...
Alors, goûtez-le.
-Il y a plein de fruits
sur l'île Maurice.
Vous faites pas des crumbles
aux fruits tropicaux ?
-Crumble aux pommes.
-Bon, vous le goûtez,
et on écoute cette musique
que vous avez choisie
pour terminer cette émission.
-Et si j'étais né en 17
A Leidenstadt
Sur les ruines
D'un champ de bataille
Aurais-je été meilleur
Ou pire que ces gens
-On a reconnu
Jean-Jacques Goldman.
Pourquoi cette chanson ?
-Déjà, j'aime beaucoup
Jean-Jacques Goldman.
Je pense que...
-Bon choix.
-C'est l'auteur-compositeur
que j'écoute en boucle
dans la voiture.
J'aime beaucoup.
Et cette chanson
plus particulièrement
parce qu'elle veut dire
beaucoup de choses.
Déjà, le sujet du choix personnel,
de l'engagement
dans un contexte historique
qui peut évoluer,
qui peut être différent
en fonction des actualités,
et puis parce que
ça montre...
On entend Jean-Jacques Goldman,
mais il y a
trois chanteurs
dans cette chanson.
Au début,
c'est sur la montée
du nazisme.
Ensuite, il y a un deuxième passage,
c'est l'apartheid,
ou je crois
que c'est le troisième,
et ensuite,
il y a un autre passage
sur les conflits
qu'il y avait eu
entre les catholiques
et les protestants
en Irlande. Ensuite,
les trois voix se retrouvent
sur la fin de la chanson.
Ca montre qu'en fait,
on est tous responsables
de nos choix,
qui ne sont pas
toujours évidents
au regard
du contexte historique
dans lequel on est,
mais que cet engagement
et cette capacité de faire,
elle ne dépend que de nous,
en fait.
-Merci, Prisca Thevenot,
d'avoir accepté
notre invitation.
Merci au restaurant
Les Mascareignes
pour ce très bon bol renversé,
et merci à Chez Françoise.
A la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro
sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
-OU LE PIRE
OU LE PLUS BEAU
SERIONS-NOUS DE CEUX
QUI RESISTENT
OU BIEN LES MOUTONS
D'UN TROUPEAU
S'IL FALLAIT PLUS QUE DES MOTS ?